when you cast for dick night or any of
the other short films you've done do you
look at some social media and say wow
this person was great compared to this
other person they both or maybe one is
better than the other in the audition
but this person has more Twitter
followers this one's more popular on
Facebook
I mean I haven't looked at it in that
regard at least in my experience you
know and I'm having dealt with
productions well we're having you know
we weren't dealing with like so to speak
name actors and and certainly Twitter
wasn't you know where was just barely
around when I think we started
production in 2010 on this movie so I
don't know whether that would become an
issue I mean probably not I'm em I think
the social media stuff gets a little
overblown when you start you know it's
hard enough to make a good movie and
that's all today eat ultimately going to
be if you make a good movie it'll it can
be undeniable against any you know
social media set the social media stuff
almost becomes important as like a
safety net for your movie and that's not
to say it's a bad thing most movies
aren't great you know and so it might
give you a little bit of a hold of well
we can probably get it out there and get
it seen by this number of people because
we have this kind of network and and
maybe keep you going if you're moved
because you have I mean talk to make a
good movie and so it's certainly worth
acknowledging and not discounting but to
put it in in the way of letting yourself
make a good movie i think would be a
mistake
do you do your social media for tonight
are you the one that me and you know my
producer he's Charles gerosa he's
probably he kind of handles more of that
than myself and you know and it were I'm
no expert by any means
you